hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game uh from round five of the
semi-finals of the chess.com Global
Chess Championship Finals 2022 it is
Anish giri versus nihal sarin and I saw
this game while I was taking medo for a
walk
um uh I saw uh saw it on Twitter Fabi
said that it's a perfect game but Anish
it's a beautiful Victory so Fabi spoiled
it for me I'm spoiling it for you but it
is the moves that we are interested in
and this game definitely has some
beautiful moves the the game basically
ends uh in in a few moves right after
the opening uh but then you are required
to show that you are truly better it's
uh something like um if you know that uh
game Bobby Fisher played against Samuel
rashevski where he uh won the queen on
move 10 I believe and then uh rashevsky
just played until move 40 but he could
have resigned on move 10 so it's not as
bad as that game but it's um well you
you'll just see what I mean so Anish has
the white pieces and he opens with E4
and here we have a mood that we don't
see every day and that is Knight the C6
some of that you will not see in
classical chess but for Rapid uh it can
do wonders if you catch your opponent by
surprise and here uh nikal Salin goes
for the names of each defense with Pawn
to D4 uh sorry first Knight to F3 uh we
have pawned the D6 and pawn to D for now
by an each Knight with uh six we have
Knight to C3 and pawn to G6 now
preparing to think into the dark Square
Bishop we have Bishop to E3 going for
the standard setup Queen D2 Bishop to H6
is the plan Bishop G7 Queen D2 and here
nihal just castles with Pawn to D5 you
could uh Castle Queen side or or
something like um H3 but Anish has a
very clear idea of what he wants to do
D5 is a great move because if you go to
E5 then you mess a black spawn structure
this way and then you play some like F3
you have a very nice Center and if you
go to B4 then you kick it away further
on A6 and then you mess up black spawn
structure this way and then you go
Bishop H6 or something
but here after D5 and eagle goes back a
knight to B8 this is the standard plan
and now only now Bush chapter H6 we have
pawned the C6 now attacking anisha's uh
strong Center and now uh there is a move
where Bishop captures on G7 was played
so we are still in known territory and
it's actually from a game uh that Anish
played against Jeffrey shonga in the
2019 fide World Cup in Hunty mask is in
Russia uh that Anish lost after Bishop
captures on G7 even though Bishop
captures and G7 is the top move
recommended by the engine but here Anish
doesn't follow this game maybe he
figured out okay I know what nihal is
doing he found that game he saw I played
some weird moves I'm just gonna Castle
Queen side and it is now as of move 9
that we have a completely new game so
okay Bishop to G4 and Ponte H4 and now
you know what anisha's plan is he wants
to push the pawn Alto all the way to H5
sacrifice the pawn and then of course
even sacrifice The Rook as this is a
very thematic sacrifice in positions
such as this one with Knight beat the D7
and pawn to H5 Bishop captures on H5 and
now uh we have a lot of Trades here
bishop captress and G7 King characters
and now Pawn to E5 and it's a very
complicated position where uh nikal if
he wants to survive he has to play
Knight captures on E5 which he didn't
here after Knight captures on E5 uh the
point is uh you could play Knight
captures on E5 and you should uh your
point is that if you move the bishop
then the H file opens up for the White
Queen Queen H6 checking Jade and now
just Knight E4 and black resigns if you
capture it's Checkmate if you don't
capture then white will capture with
check and then deliver Checkmate so
whatever you do you're getting
checkmated so basically after Knight
captures on E5 you're gonna have to
recapture the Knight and then comes
spawn to F3 G4 you attack the bishop you
still gain access to the H6 Square so it
might be
manageable for black but still it's a
much better position for white however
in the game uh nihal played D captures
on E5 and now this is big trouble for
him the captures on C6 banish attacking
the Knight B captures and now of course
Rook captures an H5 saying that if you
capture with the Knight then the Knight
no longer defends this Knight and it
would be a very very sad to play this
position with black yes you have a rook
for two pieces but it's not really all
that impressive it's bishop and Knight
for a rook and also this Pawn is hanging
this Pawn is hanging this Pawn is weak
this Pawn is weak uh this would be a
very very nice win for white so instead
G captures an H5 but this also now means
that with the King and G7 the queen
having access to G5 it's a very hard to
get out of all the threats and now comes
Knight captures on E5 and this adds a
third attacker to the Knight on D7 so
now you can just uh well if you if you
don't move the Knight then you just lose
the piece so anihal does the only thing
left for him and that is Knight captures
on E5 he has to give up the queen and
Anish grabs it the queen to G5 with the
check Knight the G6 and now Rook
captures on d8 we have Rook F captures
on d8 and now comes Queen to C5 so the
position is still very much playable for
black but it is not not easy to hold
this as there are many many weaknesses
so here here Rook the D6 defending the
C6 pawn and pawn to B3 now you have to
improve your position on the queen side
so black cannot just use the Rooks and
knights to attack your king Ponte H4 and
now Pawn to A4 we have rooked the E6 and
now King the B2 getting your king to
save you don't want to run into
something like rookie one check and then
you lose the bishop so King B2 and now
Pawn to A5 with Bishop to D3 by Anish
Pawn to H6 and now Knight to E2 the
Knight cannot come to F4 if the knight
from G6 moves or you can come to D4 then
to F5 with check if if uh nothing is
played here so it's a very very hard for
black to find the plan so here uh nihal
tries Knight to the E5 but now just the
bishop to F5 goes after The Rook okay
you don't lose the Rook because you have
a way out Knight e37 now attacks the
queen queen C4 and now Knight to B6
attacks the queen again Queen to D3 and
now the Rook moves Rook the E5 putting
pressure on the bishop here Bishop back
to H3 and now Knight B to D5 so nikhail
definitely finding a very nice counter
play here Knights the D4 and now comes
Pawn to E6 you have to give up the C6
Pawn there's no good way to defend it if
you move at Knight F5 check and this is
just um well then you give up the H6
Pawn you cannot defend it if you go King
H7 then you go under the mask of the
queen uh and whatever you do isn't
really all that impressive so Pawn to E6
and now Knight captures on C6 attacks
The Rook on E5 and now comes Rook the G5
uh the probably last attempt at maybe
maybe playing this is night before
attacking the White Queen and the Knight
kind of forcing a trade here on B4 uh
but still white would have this very
nice Bishop to G4 it's not an easy move
to find but with the black king being
wide in the open it will uh of course a
player of unicious caliber will will
spot this instantly point is that now if
Knight captures then you have Queen to D
for attacking The Rook attacking the
Knight and you will win back your
material you will win back the B4 Point
eventually and then the three connected
pass pawns on the queen side will do
good work so after Knight captures on C6
Rook to G5 instead we have Queen to D
for now uh not allowing the Knight on F6
to move and you will eliminate one of
the Defenders with Pawn to C4 so Rook
the A6 attacks the Knight here Knights
the E5 and now Rook the B6 but now just
Pawn to C4 and now you are dislodging
the Knight that's defending the Rook
here so Rook the B4 is needed now the
Knight cannot be capped and now comes
Knight the C6 attacking The Rook on B4
now Knight the C6 is uh winning uh
without without any questions but I will
just show Bishop captures on E6 because
it's really awesome point is that after
captures you have Queen A7 check and now
the knife controlling uh F7 and G6 you
have to go somewhere if you go here then
Knight F7 check picks up the The Rook on
G6 on G5 and that if King to Jade
doesn't matter Queen to F7 checking h8
now Knight the G6 check you force a
trade hero captures Queen captures and
yes you have two knights and Rook for a
queen but the this Knight has to move
and then this Knight will hang so
completely winning for white so Knight
the C6 instead by Anish we have Pawn to
E5 now attacking the queen queen A7 and
now Knight the F4
uh and now not going going for The Rook
uh but rather Knight the d8 it's more
important to go after the F7 Pawn as it
cannot be defended we have Knights the
H7 and now Knight captures an F7
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries like this one so King to F6
getting the king out of Harm's Way and
now comes Knight captures and G5 and
again the position is completely winning
for a niche but for your viewing
pleasure I will show a forced Checkmate
in 12 uh that is Knight to D6 and now
you are basically threatening mate in
one as the bishop covers uh df5 and D6
squares uh the only way to defend this
King Rook to G7 and now this Fork uh
nicely uh starts the king can't King G5
Queen captures and G7 check Knight the
G6 and now again Knight to D6 absolutely
yeah beautiful Knight F6 Knight to F7
with check King to F4 and now Queen
captures an H6 checking E4 and now Queen
to E3 will be Checkmate as the bishop
covers F5 and the pawn covers D5 so okay
it's winning whatever you do but it's a
fourth line so I know you guys enjoy uh
such lines so Knight captures on G5 was
played with Knight captures and G5 and
now Queen captures on A5 now threatening
The Rook here Knight the E4 by nihal uh
one last attempt at tricking an issue
because if you capture a knight to D3
check Forks the king and the Queen and
then let's say you captures captures uh
but still three connected pass points on
the queen side will be winning for Anish
so it's more of a
uh you know just trying to hang in there
and hope for something move uh Queen to
d8 with check with King to F7 and now
Pawn to A5 starting to advance the pawn
here Knight captures an F2 Now Pawn to
A6 we have Knight 2 to D3 with check and
now King the C3 we have Pawn to E4 A7 we
have Knight the E2 with check and King
to D2 uh and it was in this position
animal 45 that Neil sarin resigned to
the game and Anish takes the lead in
their match as this was the fifth game
of the match uh first two games they
exchanged the wins and then game three
and four ended in a draw and now Anish
wins the fifth game of their semi-final
match so here you resign as next move
white gets a queen and there's no way to
continue the attack you could try
something like Knight E to C1 and maybe
try and push a pawn but still white gets
a queen You're Gonna Play Knight
captures on B3 with check and then after
King E3 there's just no way to continue
the king Hunter and of course the black
well I have to resign at some point
so yeah after King 32 nihal resigned and
Anish takes the lead and uh I don't know
it it it's a it's a wonderful game it's
uh it's hard to say if the game can be
salvaged uh after uh this uh uh D
captures an E5 move Knight captures an
E5 and black can probably hold probably
not in a practical game but after this
exchange Euro capture spawn captures and
queen G5 check winning the black queen
uh probably with with a perfect play uh
maybe you can hold this with black but
you've seen that it's uh not not all
that easy even though uh both nihal and
Anish played pretty much all engine
moves for for the entire game uh Anish
was just able to uh outplay him as he
was up material
uh so yeah that's the game I hope you
guys enjoyed it uh names of which had
many great ideas about this opening
obviously was not one of them but what
you're gonna do sometimes it's gonna
work against your opponent like he did
for Jeffrey Sean when he played it
against Anish in 2019 video World Cup
but uh now it didn't even though this is
rapid Anish of course improved on that
game and he didn't allow himself to get
surprised because you always have to
stay on top you have to even the the
like a spot offset it's not only
important to analyze and improve the
games you've lost but also the games
that you've won because your opponents
will find what you've messed up even in
the games that you want so those are
maybe even more important to analyze
uh so yeah that's the game I hope you
guys enjoyed it do you agree with Fabi
that this is a perfect game by a niche
it is definitely beautiful Victory I
don't know if it's a perfect game but it
definitely is uh is a nice one uh so
yeah once again really hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank Jacoby
the guncalo morobo Martin
and uh subramanian for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day